since Tesla unveiled its 35 thousand
dollar car so many of our questions have
been answered it's fast it's roomy it
has a long range and it's hot but there
are still two huge questions that remain
number one can Tesla build it on time
Tesla has a long history of the latest
every time the company unveils a new car
and begins taking reservations Elon Musk
gives a projected launch day and every
single time Tesla has missed these
deadlines most recently coming in within
18 months behind schedule the second
question is even more critical for Tesla
can the model 3 be profitable Tesla has
been burning through billions of dollars
to get ready for this car and if the
model 3 can't be profitable at its 35
thousand dollar price point there are
going to be problems Tesla needs to cut
costs and for an electric car that means
reducing the price of the battery
battery prices in general have been
falling fast the Tesla still needs to
shave off another thirty percent or so
for the muddle three numbers to work out
that's why the company is building the
world's biggest battery factory the
first stage is already producing packs
ahead of schedule and when the final
stage is complete it will have the
largest footprint of any building on the
planet there are still so many things
that must go right for Tesla in the next
two years but the company's existential
questions have changed the biggest
challenge is no longer about how to
convince drivers to go electric they've
clearly already done that now it's about
how to meet the overwhelming demand for
the model 3